soirée salsa me sommes de retour sur
terre toujours en compagnie de bernard
kouchner
de josé nicolas
bon michael youn locale ouch violents a
dit
et on passe maintenant un homme tu es au
top de la semaine
[Musique]
mulcair une robe en soie
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs
celui qui se foutait un poil en hurlant
dans un mégaphone quand il était jeune
et qui maintenant va devoir expliquer à
sa fille pourquoi ils se foutaient à
poil en hurlant dans un mégaphone quand
il était jeune
m
[Musique]
aujourd'hui michael vous vous êtes
assagi vous êtes ici ce soir pour un
film sérieux est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est le film de la maturité comme on
dit quand on a absolument aucune
question à poser
j'en avais fait d'autres avant des films
sérieux mais malheureusement les gens
étaient pas vraiment venu les voir voilà
suis là je pense que ça va changer
ça s'appelle carbone s'est réalisée par
olivier marchal avec vous avec benoît
magimel gérard depardieu dany laura smet
y lire chanteur et grains le pitch c'est
l'histoire de benoît magimel qui se
retrouve au poste parce qu'on l'a arrêté
en sens interdit avec un dealer dans sa
voiture
ça c'est le parisien ces parisiens ça
c'est le vrai pitch le vrai pitch benoît
magimel est obligé de déposer le bilan
de sa société il est désavoué par sa
femme et son beau père depardieu en part
en live in connection et magimel décide
avec l'aide de son comptable vous de
monter une fraude à la taxe carbone pour
se refaire mais le grand banditisme va
s'intéresser aux tonnes de pognon aux
kids ramasse et ça va mal finir
ces tirs et évidemment d'une histoire
vraie d'une histoire s'est passé en 2007
2008 en france avec une petite bande de
jeunes qui a priori n'était pas des
spécialement des des escrocs qui ont
détourné 1 milliard 800 millions à
l'union européenne ouais en un an à 10
voilà il y en a quatre qui sont morts
ouais alors c'est vrai que c'est un film
excellent là olivier marchal est au
sommet de son art c'est un vrai polar
comme on aime alors c'est la remarque du
siècle 1 c'est beaucoup plus larnack du
siècle que le quinquennat de françois
hollande qui n'a rien à dire elle
proteste
quelle belle histoire bah je sais pas
j'ai pas beaucoup de jus pas beaucoup de
respect pour les escrocs et les
escroqueries angers lui c'est son métier
donc il ya non c'est à dire que on peut
interpréter ces personnages là on on
leur donne des circonstances atténuantes
pour pouvoir justement être dans le rôle
maintenant voilà moi je n'aurais pas été
capable de faire ce qu'on fait l'âge du
film non absolument j'ai plutôt bien
élevé en fait alors magimel c'est vrai
que son état physique finalement est
très utile aux films non c'est vrai que
pendant le tournage benoît était pas
super super bien après sans dire que
olivier a utilisé cet état mais c'est
vrai que cet état certes c'est rohff il
met donc à faire autant à benoît à sa
performance absolument mais voilà il se
bat benoît il va y arriver il va mieux
déjà et voilà ils essayent de s'en
sortir mais c'est pas pour rien que la
drogue ça s'appelle la drogue c'est
parce que c'est difficile mais je sais
très bien ce que c'est malheureusement
c'est terrible tout ce qu'on peut dire
aux gens c'est de pampres voilà c'est
qu'on admire mais
très bien en chine est bien bien vu
qu'il est très bien l'art c'est le sac
de riz ce sera toute sa vie
avec le cube et moi c'est sucer c'est
tromper on a chacun notre truc notre
étiquette qu'on se soit même collé voilà
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on fait c'est
comme ça vous êtes convaincant comptable
mais j'avais fait des études de commerce
dans ma vie j'ai fait une super de
gauche master en management center ouais
c'est vrai mais gérer mes billets je
t'emmerde
il ya mon pilote de moto le bien sûr le
chari jesse bond la d'embrasser qui joue
dans le film
c'est le talent de marshall c'est de
reconnaître cependant autour de lui dans
sa vie où que ce soit au milieu des
collègues il va tout de suite choper la
gueule qui va l'intéresser pour son
prochain alors vous pouvez toujours et
maintenant vous avez joué d'ailleurs une
réincarnation de jésus
dans christophe l'envoi les envoie des
photos la voix là alors c'est peut-être
une réincarnation on a la réponse
française pas devenir blasphématoire
évidemment parce qu'il s'avérerait que
jésus se serait réincarné dans un
connard voilà voilà donc
en tous les cas si cette fois vous êtes
crucifié par la critique ce sera un
hommage alors évitez tombe vous revenu
en force je suis d'accord avec vous mais
vous savez les médias n'ont pas manqué
ouais donc vous êtes au courant là
regardez comme c'est terrible ça les 11
commandements w9 mais que devient
michael youn alors ça c'est terrible
c'était comme ça 25 juillet 2010 est à
15h07 sur le site télé loisirs à
l'occasion de la énième rediffusion de
votre film les 11 commandements qui a
été diffusée 27 fois depuis 2000 soit là
c'est à dire c'est le cinquième film le
plus diffusé dans l'union à part ça
cette fois et non mais j'ai motion en
plus je suis pas producteur du dossier
par rené le padfone sûrs non cancéreux
diffusé j'ai rien pris alors cet article
fatidique que toutes les stars redoute
non que devient bernard kouchner que
devient camille c'est à dire ça c'est le
moment le plus difficile
après c'est danse avec les stars ça on y
est confronté tous les jours dans la rue
tous les jours il ya des gens qui vous
arrête et qui vous disent mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous l'avez donné ça fait
longtemps qu'on vous a pas vu exemple
dire on vous voit plus à la télé jeudi
faut l'allumer connard
moi je dis que c'est au chômage et les
gens vivent
ça va mais tout va super bien
franchement si ça va ça va très très
bien on sent bien que ça va pas d'une
force puis j'imagine que votre fille
vous aide à relativiser à baisser parce
qu'elle me prend beaucoup de temps bah
oui c'est vrai que ça c'est devenu plus
beau métier de ma vie c'est pas grave
bah ouais excusez moi d'être un peu
fleur non mais t'as raison non mais bien
sûr il a fallu sa gamine depuis deux ans
le nord mais c'est pas ça via twitter
des photos avec elle à six enjeux précis
est ce qu'elle vous a pardonné de
l'avoir appelée seven bas elle adore son
prénom puisqu'elle est la seule à le
porter en métal marque elle sera pu être
star wars s'il s'agissait de prendre un
petit de films que vous aimez non
c'était pas un titre de film c'est parce
qu'il ya cette lettre dans je t'aime
dans je t'aime et je n'ai pas l'appeler
cette société seven c'était plus les
plus cool vous avez l'air bien ensemble
et bush fils ma fille m'a demandé c'est
quoi les impôts papa j'ai mangé la
matière sont pas anglais elle a compris
a l'air de bien avec la regardera tu
vois tu le mets qui kiffent avec sa
fille et là on voit bien là les gérants
pas des chats on voit que c'est votre
fille à la prochaine étape c'est la dass
et ça même si je suis un bon papa oui je
pense que non parce que là on la voit
faire des doigts là on se dit ah didon
ça l'éducation on pense que vous êtes un
bon parce que vous intéresser à mon
gosse intéressez vous aux vôtres
est ce qu'un psy voulu chanter vos
chansons pour l'endormir malheureusement
oui
beaucoup de gens elle adore ça seulement
quand elle est punie elle adore ça elle
se met même à les chanter elle même et
je m'aperçois effectivement que mes
chansons dites stupide marche bien sûr
les enfants musique
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
monde pourquoi oui pourquoi je suis né
dans le tabac
d'accord
et dans la récré où il ajouté je vendais
les
coût
non
faute à quelques jours
[Musique]
mais c'est pas si j'assume le couché
qu'avec
extraordinaire
[Musique]
mais quinze ans
il y a
et je mets
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi maintenant mais on va
faire une interview trait d'union
peut-être parce que
[Musique]
c'est que des mots existerait d'union
est ce que vous êtes fut de chute ah non
je suis plutôt concon ouais un peu plus
[__] peu fut un peu con con avec sympa
ce côté en tant qu'équipe et interviews
pour une fête tire larmes
vous connaissez je suis plus tire fesses
que tire à l'abri
êtes bingbing bab fait un plan sur les
chaussures ah ouais les chaussures s'il
vous plaît
walsh me
fait me sentir
à huy où les passants sûr que quand je
tiens je tiens franchement merci est ce
que vous êtes laisse cul
oui avec plaisir ça dépend lequel qu'on
s'est demandé gentiment quand c'est le
vôtre avec grand plaisir
de faire valoir
pareil ça dépend avec qui concer faire
valoir de magimel dans un film de
marshall avec grand plaisir voilà bonne
réponse
est-ce que je tire bouchon oui sans
modération surtout avec marchal et de
parts du gâteau vous êtes moule [__]
pas tellement il peut je suis plus ce
soir je suis plus moules frites que mon
but mais le tard hier pensée
savez ce que je pense de ton interview
de merde
et corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu